hey 42 here in 1992 a man was fleeing
from the los angeles police department
after spending the night drinking with
friends and watching basketball he had
entered his car
and driven home not long after two
officers noticed his car speeding down
the highway
spotting his pursuers the man sped up
his vehicle and tried to escape
he was already on parole for a previous
robbery conviction
and couldn't risk a charge for driving
under the influence
[Music]
the chase was on several police cars
joined and eventually a helicopter was
tailing him from above
and after eight miles of pursuit through
highways and residential streets
the man was cornered he was removed from
his vehicle reportedly gagged and forced
to the ground
and then the story took a darker turn
the man was tasered and for 15 minutes
savagely beaten
with batons across the elbows knees and
ankles
repeatedly kicked and dragged on his
stomach to the side of the road
all whilst as multiple witnesses would
state the man
wasn't appearing to resist
and disturbingly at least for the police
all of this
was caught on camera the man was a black
man named rodney king
and the video of his assault at the
hands of police was about to ignite one
of the largest riots
in u.s history the footage soon went
viral and charges were brought against
the officers involved
but when they had their day in court
they were acquitted the now famous
footage had stirred up
deep resentment amongst black
communities across the united states
and the acquittal of what was obvious to
everyone even the president as a violent
assault
proved to be a step too far within hours
of the verdict the center of los angeles
was swarming with thousands of rioters
engaging in arson looting even assault
in a prolonged expression of mass
rage and angst that lasted six days
the police were completely overwhelmed
with neither the manpower nor the
resources to deal with it
and their police chief daryl gates who
was notoriously aggressive
and took a paramilitary approach to law
enforcement
failed to de-escalate the situation
despite king's now-famous plea of
can't we all just get along the riots
escalated to the point where the
national guard several law enforcement
agencies
and the us military itself were forced
to step in to end the civil unrest
when the dust cleared over 60 people had
been killed
more than 2 300 were injured and over 12
arrested koreatown had been ravaged with
destruction and
in total the property damage across los
angeles exceeded 1 billion us dollars
but on the bright side there was no
communist commune
riots have long been a fixture in human
society
in medieval england it was illegal to
not
take part in a riot because it was
viewed as suspicious
reactions to extreme poverty inadequate
living conditions
unemployment government oppression
corruption ethnic group conflicts or
even the result of sports games riots
take several forms and typically exist
without a clear leader spurned on by
an irrational herd mentality that cannot
and will not be easily stopped
riots are usually instigated by and ride
on the back of a wave of primal emotions
such as sadness
anger fear disgust and even jealousy
but once rioting begins the original
message which may have been
positive and constructive is often
forgotten
and consumed by base political
ideologies
and destruction whilst the opportunistic
herd
loot and murder and
thus riots can be one of the most
terrifying forces of humanity one can
face
and the consequences can be dire far
exceeding the depravity of the original
injustice
with that in mind what follows are some
of the most terrifying riots in human
history
it was 2002 in the western indian state
of gujarat
the sabarmati express having returned
from ayodhya
had stopped near the godra railway
station carrying a bevy of hindu
pilgrims
returning from a religious ceremony but
on the station platform
something terrible happened a mass
argument broke out between the
passengers and the railway platform
vendors
and soon it became violent for reasons
unknown the violence spread onto the
train and
fire broke loose all whilst many were
still trapped inside
as the conflagration swept through the
train
nine men 25 women and 25 children
all burnt to death the instigators were
said to be members
of a muslim mob a widespread outrage
amongst the hindu community spread with
the target of its anger being the muslim
community and the government
the chief minister at the time narendra
modi
declared the burning an act of terrorism
and local newspapers used his statement
to incite violence
against a muslim community claims were
made of a pakistan conspiracy and false
news stories claimed hindu women
had been kidnapped and raped the day
after the train fire
precise highly coordinated attacks began
using government-issued lists of muslim
homes and businesses
attackers began to systematically
assault the muslim population
who when they sought help from the
police were met with the response
we have no orders to save you terrified
alone and outnumbered the few muslims
who attempted to defend themselves
were fired upon by police
and a few lucky ones found themselves
protected by brave hindus
who saw no need for violence when all
was said and done
the riots ended with a hundred and 000
people
displaced 230 mosques destroyed
233 missing 2 500
injured and over 1 000 dead with some
estimates reaching 2000.
extremely violent murders and rapes
occurred and there was widespread
looting and property damage
modi the now prime minister of india was
accused of inciting the rioters
in 1863 the american civil war was well
underway but the opposition that u.s
president abraham lincoln faced
wouldn't just be from the confederate
forces it would be from civil unrest in
none other
than new york city new laws recently
passed by congress had meant that men
were beginning to get
drafted into the war effort against the
south in an effort to abolish slavery
but not everyone was pleased about this
white working-class anger had grown in
response to the draft with the feeling
that free black americans
would be extra competition for already
hard to come by jobs
and that the poor working-class whites
were being sent to the war in droves
whilst rich men were able to buy their
way out of it by paying the 300
commutation fee roughly 6 100
today why fight for people who will just
take your jobs and leave you starving
or for people who had paid money to sit
back whilst you do the fighting for them
these were the thoughts swimming in the
minds of the poor white population
at the time and as we've learned huge
waves of the population feeling
anger and resentment isn't a good thing
and a huge race riot soon followed
with what started as a protest against
the draft soon developing into savage
attacks
of white predominantly irish immigrants
on black communities throughout new york
city
the riots lasted four days on monday the
draft officers were attacked
with having stones smashed through the
windows and one building was set ablaze
when fire men turned up to the scene
their vehicles were destroyed
and their horses were killed telegraph
lines were cut
to prevent warnings of the growing riot
police were charged down
overpowered and terribly beaten
newspaper officers in countless
buildings were burned
numerous black americans were tortured
and killed
one in particular was swarmed by a
mother 400
beaten hung from a tree and set on fire
an orphanage for black american children
was looted and countless businesses that
promoted integration
were destroyed on tuesday social figures
such as prison reformer abby gibbons
were targeted with attacks
as well as white women who were married
to black men
and by wednesday and thursday the
military had been called in and after
numerous clashes
order was restored and the riots came to
an end
when it was over 11 black men had been
lynched and hanged
and some estimates state that 120 to 2
000 people
were killed and 8 000 injured there were
83 million dollars in property damage
and many black american families left
manhattan for good
fearing rightfully for their safety
now you're probably thinking what on
earth could be worse than that
i mean just imagine a mob of 400 people
hunting you down
purely based on how you look to vents
their anger on you and kill you
pretty horrifying right well imagine a
riot that burned nearly half your city
to the ground and saw tens of thousands
of people slaughtered
that's exactly what happened in 532
a.d constantinople you see
chariot races back then were a big deal
and by
big deal i mean a really big deal
everyone had a team they supported who
were differentiated by colours such as
blues and greens
these teams were associated with gangs
political parties
religious issues and more the races were
an outlet for the social issues plaguing
society at the time
amplifying and heightening the divide
between peoples
and hugely influencing the urban flow of
power between the people and their
rulers
in fact chariot teams used to shout
political demands during races as they
knew how much the imperial forces
struggled to maintain order
without the bread and circuses that the
chariot race is so regularly supplied
in other words the chariot races were a
god powder keg
waiting to go off to add more gunpowder
to this already explosive environment
the emperor justinian the first was an
unpopular ruler who had levied high
taxes
gone to war unsuccessfully against the
persians and
in 531 when two charioteers were
implicated in a murder
made the grand old decision of banning
the races for a year
when you rule a race mad population
this is not exactly the best idea
on the 13th of january 5 32 race day
finally came again and a furious
agitated a ready to explode populous
began to stuff itself into the
hippodrome which happens to be next to
justinian's palace
as the races began everyone started to
cheer their team names but soon they
began to hurl insults at justinian
and by race 22 the whole crowd was up in
arms losing their mind of rage
screaming nika which means conquer
within minutes the crowd was assaulting
justinian's palace in what must still be
the largest football hooligan riot
in history this would be like the
well-dressed enormous
hat-wearing clientele at ascot race
courses
losing their minds and marching on
windsor castle an event which no doubt
would cause prince andrew to finally
sweat the attacks lasted for five days
and the fires that spread from the
rioting mob burned half the city to ash
including the original higher sophia and
killed hundreds of people but the
emperor
justinian the first convinced by his
wife not to flee
had a simple response to these riots
kill
everyone and kill everyone
he did turning the two teams blue
and green against one another justinian
sent imperial troops into the hippodrome
and ordered them to
slaughter anyone who was there killing
over thirty thousand rioters
indiscriminately and without mercy
sure enough not long after this the nika
riots
came to an end but not before
demonstrating that whilst race or
religious differences can drive
people crazy nothing really ticks us off
like not being allowed to watch our
favorite sport
thanks for watching you can now
pre-order my brand's new book stick a
flag in it
on amazon link in the description thank
you